BO MAJEWSKI: Before I dive into
the API, let me quickly
introduce ourselves.
My name is Bo Majewski.
I've been with Google for
five and a half years.
I started on the Geocoding API,
joined the Wave, hence
you didn't see me
for three years.
And then right now I'm working
on App Engine.
Ged?
GED ELLIS: Yeah.
Hi, I'm Ged Ellis.
And I also worked on Wave for a
couple of years, working on
search and notifications.
And recently-- the last
six months or so--
I've been working on search
in App Engine.
All right.
BO MAJEWSKI: So just to gauge
the audience, how many of you
have used anything like
Lucene Solr, Whoosh?
OK, so you're very much familiar
with the reasons for
doing this.
Any time you want to have
something like a bunch of
documents, and you want to allow
users to find the right
documents by entering just a few
key terms, you would use a
text search API.
If you have a feed, usually it's
filled with information
about people eating breakfast
and going to sleep.
And from time to time you want
something more relevant, so
you would search it as well.
Gmail changed the approach to
email by focusing on search
rather than on foldering and
cataloging your email.
So again, this pretty much
uses the search API, text
search API.
And finally, every time you go
to Amazon, eBay, where you
have hundreds of thousands of
products, you use text search
API to narrow your searches.
So about three years ago, an
Issue 217 has been filed,
which since then somehow
mysteriously
drifted to number two.
And the person who filed it--
noted that, since we are
Google, we pretty much should
provide the text search API.
So we actually agree--
[APPLAUSE]
BO MAJEWSKI: It just took
us a while to get to it.
What I'm going to talk about
today, and Ged, first we're
going to present you
with a core--
what we call core--
search API.
This is a more low-level
approach.
Those who do not use
Datastore directly.
The second part of our talk is
going to be integrating this
with Datastore.
How do you use it
with Datastore?
And finally we're going to
mention our plans for REST
API, which allows you to exist
outside the app engine
altogether.
As you might be aware, what is
available today, you have
essentially two possibilities.
You can either rely
on the Datastore.
And Datastore allows you to
store texts and strings.
And you can use the
equality/inequality.
And in case of lists, you
can test for membership.
Or you can do anything
you can do over HTTP.
So you either do a self-hosted
solution, where you put up
your instance of Lucene and just
query it, or you go to a
third party.
However, this is not the
most convenient thing.
What Ged is going to
show you is what is
available right now.
We actually have it working.
And there is no more appropriate
way of showing it
than showing you with a '90s
style application, the guest
book you can put on
your webpage.
OK.
GED ELLIS: OK.
So, yeah.
We have some guest book
application built on top of
search API.
There's three sections, I guess,
to this demo page.
There's a little comment box
here, where you can type in
comments, a search box where you
can search for comments,
and then a list of search
results, which is the comments
which match the current
search.
So the current search
is all comments.
And then you've got some other
fields here, like the author
who wrote it and the
date published.
So let's go ahead and
make a comment.
So "I'll be back." So we're
making comments basically just
quotes from movies.
And we'll hashtag it
with #terminator.
And I'm going to shout
out to Bo.
So that gets added to the index
and is returned in the
current search, which
is all comments.
So you've got the
comment there.
I said, who wrote it.
So it's anonymous.
And published today.
And you can see that I'm
currently signed in anonymous.
No one is signed in.
So let's do some searches.
So I could search for simple
terms, like fish.
So that'll find all the comments
that mention fish.
You can see that it supports
CJK, so I can search for just
the character fish.
I can do more complicated
searches like combinations of
terms. Like "be back." And
you'll see it'll match the
comment I wrote before.
Also, it's "I'll be back"--
back "to be or not to
be" is a best quote.
But if I want to actually
match this, I
can do a phrase query.
So that's just showing some of
the sorts of queries we can do
that this supports.
So it'll only find "be back."
You can restrict
your searches.
So I can search for things
that I wrote.
So you can see that, in fact,
it searches for Ged in the
author field.
So you can restrict to,
obviously, anonymous, so
things that have been
anonymously written.
You could also search for
other things, like tags.
So if I want to search
for gladiator--
oops, that's actually in
the wrong syntax--
so tag gladiator.
And so that finds all the
hashtags, all the comments
with hashtags and gladiator.
Similarly, if I want to find
out shout outs to Bo, that
will find all the shout outs.
So in terms of some of the more
complicated searches, so
you can search for combinations
using logical
operators like and,
or, and not.
So here we're searching for
anonymous comments that
contain the word "back" or
"machete." But I can also do
things like restrict
it to not Macbeth--
tag with #macbeth.
So it shows some of the standard
things you'd probably
find in a search site.
So, some of the other
things you can do.
Search for published ranges.
So I could find "give me all
comments that are being
written up to and including the
6th of May." And if I want
to do exclusive ranges, use
the curly brace syntax.
So that would exclude
the 6th of May.
And you can do things like
delete documents.
So I delete that comment,
and now it's no
longer in the index.
So that's showing, basically,
documents being indexed
immediately and matching
searches.
There's also pagination.
So I can just paginate
through the results.
OK.
So let's have a look at some
of the code behind that and
the concepts.
So there's two processes
in search.
There's the indexing process.
So, for example, we're
taking user data--
in our case, the user data was
the comment, the author, so
the person logged in, the
date and things like
tags and shout outs.
So there's some of the fields
that are added to documents.
So the document would be
this comment document.
That document is then given
to the indexer, which will
tokenize it and then build the
inverted file in the index.
In the search phase, you're
taking user-- or application
input in our case-- that we were
taking exactly the query
that was typed in.
That's given to a query builder,
which will build a
more formal query and give it
to the indexer back end.
And execute it against
the index.
And return a search
response, which
contains a set of documents.
And then, those documents
use a result builder and
construct, in our case, the
three little comments shown at
the bottom of the page.
So the architecture.
So I'm going to discuss
the left hand
side of this diagram.
Bo is going to talk about the
Datastore side in the second
half of the talk.
So with the application, you
construct the document.
Then you ask the indexer
to index that document.
The indexer then will write that
document to Megastore,
which will then tokenize it
and build the indexes.
An application will send
a query to the indexer.
The indexer will then issue that
query to Megastore, read
the set of results, the
entities, and convert them
into a search response.
And then the search response
is sent back up to the
application.
So you have full control
over the
document schema and content.
There is no up-front declaration
of the schema in
the gamma files.
It's actually done as you
add fields to documents.
So document content can be
arbitrarily transformed.
So in our case, we were taking
those comments, and we were
also extracting out the tags
and the shout outs.
But it could be a product
document, and you could unify
with that pricing data shipping
and offers and
reviews, et cetera, so
we could build a
full product page.
So, a typical sequence.
Create a document.
Add the documents to an index.
And then use a query to match
against that index and return
documents or snippets.
So for those who--
this should be reasonably
familiar, who've
used Lucene, et cetera.
So the document is a collection
of fields plus a
document ID.
Document ID has to be unique.
You may have language
specifications, so you can add
an indication on how it
should be tokenized.
And then there's order IDs
should also be supplied.
The order ID is used to sort
the documents by default.
And you saw with the
demonstration that those
documents were sorted from most
recent to oldest. And
that's using the default
ordering, which is the number
of seconds since January 2011.
So fields are simply a named
and typed value.
The name doesn't have to be
unique, so you can add
multiple values.
So you can have as many tags
as you want, for example.
You can specify the language
so that you can override if
you want for that particular
field.
Or you can specify
at this level.
And as mentioned before, the
schema is built as you
introduce new field
names and types.
Some of the field values
we support.
Plain text.
HTML.
So it can use a HTML parser.
Dates.
So up to a day-level granularity
in date/time, so
you have milliseconds.
Geopoints.
Numeric.
And Atom, so you can have fields
that you don't want any
tokenization and treat
as a single value.
So let's look at how you
can create a document.
Here's the Python code.
So, we have a document ID.
Set the document ID.
In this case, you'll need some
way of generating a unique
document ID.
And then you basically just
add a set of fields--
let's say there was text, HTML
and dates and Atoms. We'd
probably have two more here,
which were the tags and the
two fields.
But essentially you
name each one.
You type it.
And you give it some value.
So, the author, which is
the user nickname.
The comment, which is the actual
text from the text box.
And the date field, which
is the date today.
The Java is pretty similar
except we're using builders.
So just get a builder.
Set the document ID.
And then add a field.
And then for each field,
you have a builder.
So, you have a field builder.
You set the name.
And you set the type
of value it is.
If it's text, HTML, or date.
So as I said, the index
is fully dynamic.
So as you add those new field
names with the types, and you
index that document, that will
introduce that to the schema.
So that'll extend the schema.
We support versions.
So you can have an existing
version of an index.
You don't need to do
this, but you can.
And you could build in
a background process.
Rebuild the index.
And then hot-swap
that index out.
There's two levels of
consistency supported.
This is global or
per document.
So global is like
an inbox style.
And basically if you're putting
a label on a document,
for example like your email or
something, and you put it on
that document.
If you search for that,
you expect that
document to be retrieved.
So that all rights are committed
up to before that
search is executed.
And then there's per document,
which in a feed style, it's
not that important that if
there's other content you
aren't aware of, then if it
turns up a few seconds later,
then that's OK.
This is an issue around
Megastore, and you see the
same thing around Datastore.
It's like selecting entities.
So global basically has
around one QPS of
rights that it can support.
But per document can support
thousands QPS
throughput of rights.
So the sort of operations we
support are index and re-index
the document.
Search.
So you can search with a simple
query string or a
complex search request. So you
can override all the features
like sorting, scoring,
et cetera.
Delete document.
So you can delete by document
ID, or you can delete by
issuing a search query.
So all the documents
that match the
query will be deleted.
You can iterate through all
documents in an index.
You can get the metadata.
So the metadata would consist of
the index name, consistency
level, the schema.
Or you can activate
a version of an
index so you can hot-swap.
So how do you index documents?
Essentially, you access the
index by the index name.
If that index is not already in
the cache or has not been
created, you then create the
index using the metadata.
So you're specifying
the index name and
the consistency level.
Once you have the index, you
can add each index, each
document, or you can do a bulk
index of all your documents.
So the Java is pretty much the
same except you're using the
factory to get the index
to create it.
And then you're using
a builder to
construct the metadata.
Otherwise you just, again, can
iterate through the documents
and index them.
Or you can do a bulk index.
So as shown in the
demonstration, we had some of
the queries you could support.
So, simple terms like hello.
Phrases, so where you care
about the order.
And whether they're adjacent,
logical searches, using and,
or, and not.
Or you can restrict search
to particular fields.
Like find all the comments
written by Bob in this case.
So you can do closed
intervals.
So find all comments
published up to and
including the 1st of May.
Or you can do exclusive
ranges.
Open intervals.
So find all the products priced
between $100 and $200,
but not including
$100 and $200.
So for search, again,
you get the index.
You search.
You could either construct this
query from some source,
or you could just enter
the string.
In our case, we would have just
taken the string the user
entered, and then we would
get a search response.
The search response contains
things like the number of
documents matched, the actual
count in returned documents,
the documents--
and you essentially iterate
through that response to get
the results and get each
document and their scores.
The Java is pretty similar.
Again, you get the index.
You get a search response
when you issue the
query to the index.
And then you iterate and get
back search results, which
contain, amongst other
things, the document.
Some of the other features that
we didn't show in the
demonstration were things
like snippeting.
So, in fact, this technology
was sitting
behind Wave as well.
Here we have Sydney karaoke
as the query issued.
And snippet is basically giving
you the context of
where the best matches
in the text are.
And so, for example, here it
found karaoke and Sydney
together in a short segment of
text out of this Wave. And by
default it would give you back
snippets up to 160 characters,
and at most three snippets.
So you can build some small
representation of the document
that you wanted showing
results.
So to do snippeting, essentially
you issue a search
request. You have the query.
And then you just indicate
which fields
that you want to snippet.
So some of the other features
are paging and cursors.
So for paging, it's typical
where you'd give an index of
the results on the
different pages.
And people randomly access
those results.
So if I click on page five, for
example, then I have to
give an offset.
So if there's 20 results per
page, then I'll want to start
at result offset 100.
And the limit will be 20.
So there's a bit of a
performance hit with this
because it has to compute that
set of results up to the page
five plus the next page.
Alternatively, you can
use cursors, which
is much more efficient.
Which is the next page or more
mechanism that you see on a
lot of websites.
And cursors can be per result or
per search request. So you
can put links on each result,
or you can put it
on the whole page.
So the first time you issue the
search, you'll specify.
In this case, I'll
want a cursor per
page, so a single cursor.
And I'll return 20 results.
When they click on the next
link or the more button or
whatever, they will then issue
this request, which says, OK,
this has the cursor here.
And I want--
again, I'll want another cursor
for another next page
plus 20 results from
that cursor.
And then it's over to Bo.
BO MAJEWSKI: All right.
So once you get all the results
you probably want to
show in the most relevant
order to the
people who are searching.
As Ged mentioned, by default
we are sorting by order ID.
These are either default sort,
which comes pretty much for
free because we store
them in that order.
Or it is the sort that is being
used even if you specify
alternative sorting orders.
So what you see here is the
documents ordered by time.
And I can change it.
At the moment, this is a very
simple application, so I can
change it to author.
If author is descending,
I come on top.
And then on the subsequent
pages Ged and
anonymous will appear.
You've authorized ascending,
then anonymous
bubbles to the top.
And anonymous-- we made a lot
of comments as anonymous, so
probably around page three
Ged will appear.
OK.
But you can also do some more
complicated sorting orders.
The other way of--
I'm going to talk about
it in a second--
the other way of ordering
documents is by scoring them.
Typically, when you search on
a website, you get documents
that are most relevant.
So entertained.
Let's search for entertained.
So this is ordered by relevance,
but we can--
by relevance and time.
We can also have a simpler
scorer, which is a hit count,
which essentially will count
only the number of hits.
And in this case, they are
inverted because simply the
second phrase had more
occurrences of "are you
entertained" than
the first one.
So let me give you some
more details on that.
As I mentioned, the default
order is order ID.
If you don't assign anything to
it, the number of seconds
is assigned, so consequently--
because we return documents in
descending order by default of
order ID-- you get the freshest
documents first, the
oldest last.
You can actually override this
document if you know how to
create an order from some sort
of field to a magical integer.
You are free to do that.
And this will provide high
performance and pretty much 0
cost for your application.
Alternatively you can, in a
search query, search request.
You can say, well, I
would like to order
some different order.
And you just provide sorting
specification.
You can sort on multiple
fields.
In this case, we are sorting
by author, and the sort is
descending.
We also provide the
default value.
That means if we don't have
the author in a given
document, use this value, which
causes the document
either to bubble to the
top or to the bottom.
Once we sort them
by authors, the
secondary field is comment.
So all documents with the same
author of course will go into
the same batch.
And then the secondary
sort is applied.
You can use some of the more
complicated expressions.
So we just don't limit you
to the individual field.
You can use regular operators
of course depending on what
sort of fields you have. On
numeric fields, you can use
multiplication, addition.
You can use conditional
operators.
If something happened, then
assign this sort of score.
Otherwise assign this.
And you can use a bunch of
functions like maximum,
minimum, logarithm, et cetera.
Some examples here.
If you want to sort by price
plus tax plus shipping to give
people the total cost
of purchasing the
item, you can do that.
So you would include in a
sorting specification
expression, which is price
plus tax plus shipping at
distance from a location.
You can also construct
artificial fields.
This is probably not for
sorting, but you can actually
create artificial fields
by concatenating a
bunch of other fields.
Along with the sorting,
you also have
access to custom scoring.
You specify the custom score.
And in this case, the
expression is
maximum number of tags.
Simply count the number of
fields that you have in a
document with a given name.
So it counts the number of
fields named tag and limits
those to five.
So then, all documents with
five, six and seven tags are
considered the same.
Everything else is sorted.
If there are no tags in a given
document, the default
value is used, which
is 0 in this case.
With scoring, however,
there comes a caveat.
We have to score a
lot of documents.
If you don't tell
us how many--
because we want to make sure
that we return you the highest
scoring document-- so if you
are requesting about 20
documents, probably limit
to about a 100
where you want to score.
So just use caution.
Don't go crazy on us.
You can also use the
default scorers.
So we provide two default
scorers, match
scorer and hit count.
Hit count is mostly
for debugging.
This is very simplistic.
Match scorer is somewhat
more sophisticated.
So if it uses the term
frequency, TF, times inverted
document frequency.
So essentially, term frequency
counts how many
times the term occurs.
And inverted document
frequency counts is
proportional to how frequent
that term is on documents.
So you have the word "the",
which is in every document
that you have in a repository,
the IDF will be very low.
And consequently it will
be scored low.
Or if you have some terms that
occur multiple times on only a
few documents, then that
score will be high.
So this is a default one and
right out of the box.
Hit count essentially
is just TF.
Snippeting, Ged already
mentioned.
We provide default snippeting,
but you also can control it.
So use the snippet function,
which rather than getting the
defaults, you can say, well,
the expression to return
essentially the default snippet
is also an expression
that we return.
But here you control
it with a function.
And you say, snippet
to return is based
on field name comment.
This time match just Sydney.
Don't match karaoke.
And limit 240 characters.
The last parameter one means you
want consecutive snippets.
So don't take three pieces
of a text here.
Just take a single
piece of a text.
So you can take two pieces,
three pieces of a text, et
cetera, per document.
OK.
The original Issue 217 actually
was filed about Datastore.
So you might be wondering
what are we doing
with all these documents?
And the documents is essentially
something that
gives you full control.
If you have data stored
somewhere else in Datastore,
you probably want to
use documents.
If you have concerns about
privacy or revealing secret
information or whatever, use
your documents and create
something that's searchable and
points back to the actual
data that you want
the user to find.
However, if you store in
Datastore, this is
the section for you.
So this is the second part
of the architecture.
Rather than operating
on documents,
you operate on entities.
So now, rather than doing index
document calls, you
simply do entity put.
And there are two
possible paths.
One is it goes to the Datastore
and, under the hood,
generates a document for you,
stores that document, and in
that document it remembers
which entity it
was generated from.
Then it'll have appropriate way
of matching that document
with the entity when you
execute that search.
The other path uses Task Queue,
which will allow you to
actually do some extra
modifications.
So we also will give you
somewhat the freedom to
generate these documents
freely, without your
intervention, but later,
modify them.
Let me give you a more
detailed description.
By default, we are not going
to change the behavior of
Datastore entities.
So if you have a Datastore
entity, it has no full-text
search capabilities until you
annotate the properties of
that entity with search type.
And in this case, I have the
greeting, which is also this
guest book application entity.
And the author is annotated
with a search type Atom.
Meaning we'll not modify it.
We'll just take it as is without
further tokenization.
Comment will take it, but
will treat this as HTML.
And in this case, date is not
being indexed at all.
If you wanted the application
like we had, you probably
would have to create--
annotate the date as well
with type searchable,
with a search type.
And now we have these
two modes.
One is the what we call
fully automatic mode.
So essentially now you
execute a put.
And what happens is, in the
background, we generate document.
We store it in Megastore
and remember which
entity it came from.
In order to preserve the same
parameters, latency
parameters, as you had
on Datastore, you can
do it in two ways.
You can either tell us just
to put the entity.
And in that case we'll just
both write the entity and
write the document on the
same transaction.
So either both are committed
or nothing is committed.
Or you can say the search
index mode that is
asynchronous right.
What that means is, we will
generate the document, but
we'll return as soon
as the entity has
been stored in Datastore.
In the background, we
are going to start
processing the document.
And we'll guarantee the
eventual consistency.
So eventually that document
will be committed to a
full-text search index.
But it does not mean the moment
you put call returned,
you will be able to search
using full-text search.
Depending on which one you want,
you either want the same
performance or immediate
full-text search, you can use
one or the other.
There is a semi-automatic
mode, which allows you
intervention.
So in a most drastic approach,
you say, generate the
document, but don't do
anything with it.
Instead give it back
to my handler.
So you specify search
index mode, none--
which means we don't write
it, we just generate it--
and you specify the handler on
which we'll call you with a
serialized document.
What that allows you is further
modify the document.
The application that Ged was
showing you, for example, was
analyzing the comment field
and was extracting the
hashtags and was extracting
shout outs.
If you want to do that, this is
probably the mode in which
you would operate.
There is also a semi-automatic
mode, which is a combination
of fully automatic and
no-write mode.
In which case you simply allow
us to write the document, but
also give us a handler.
What you do with it?
It's up to you.
You can either monitor,
log, whatever.
The searching is done by
providing one extra method,
which is matches, which
takes a query.
And essentially the way it
works is it goes to the
document index, finds all the
matching documents, and
performs the intersection with
other parts of the query.
So it gives you only things
that match the full-text
search plus other limitations
you gave on the query.
The final part is
the REST API.
We pretty much are going to
follow the somewhat standard
convention of noun, selector,
noun, selector.
All nouns are plural.
Selectors are IDs of either
indexes or documents.
At the moment, we only have used
three methods, get, post,
and delete.
Now, I have to give a caveat.
This may change.
This is very early stages
of this implementation.
You've used, say, /indexes, and
you give us a get method.
We give you method about
all your indexes.
The first selector is
the index name.
So on the get, you get the
metadata about that index.
On post, you create
that index.
The parameters of the index,
like consistency and version,
all that sort of stuff, you
would specify after the
question mark.
On delete, you delete all
documents from the index and
delete the index itself.
Second noun is docs.
So if you execute a HTTP get
with /index is A/docs.
You'll get all documents
from index A.
Post method does nothing.
And delete deletes all docs,
but it retains your index.
You can actually limit which
documents you will delete by
specifying further query after
the question mark.
So then, in that case, it
means delete from A all
documents that match
given query.
And the final selector
is the document ID.
So again, /index is
/A, /docs is X.
Select the document
X from get.
And post, you create the
document, and you specify the
fields of the question marks
of the parameter.
And on delete, you delete
that specific document.
Versions are supported by
prefixing all the URLs with
appropriate V1, V2, et cetera.
As you might guess, at the
moment, it's like V.01.
Well, V1.
Pagination is supported by
offset limits and format by
appending the format
name to the noun.
In terms of a road map, I have
to be very careful, because
Mick, our Product Manager, is
watching me carefully what I'm
going to say here.
At the moment, we are just
telling you what we are
working on.
It actually works, despite
Mick's piercing eyes.
It works.
But we are going to invite
you to give us feedback.
I mean, what is missing?
What would you change?
What would you like to see?
A lot of you voted
on Issue 217.
We hope that a lot of these
people who are interested in
full-text search can give us
the feedback before we
completely nail the API.
At the moment it's fairly
stable, but we still invite
the feedback.
The first thing that
we're going to
release is the core API.
So this is the part that Ged was
talking about, where you
will have to generate
your own documents.
And you will have the freedom
of how you do it, but the
additional programming expenses
of having to do it.
Subsequently, the Datastore API
is going to be released,
in which case you will then have
these fully automatic and
semi-automatic methods
available.
And further down the line
is the REST API.
OK, to sum it up, you were given
an overview of what is
coming in the full-text
search.
Stand-alone text search coming
first. Full integration with
Datastore and the REST
API coming next.
And I guess we have
20 minutes.
So if there are any questions,
we'll just open the floor to
the questions.
And please use the
mics on the other
side, so they get recorded.
[APPLAUSE]
BO MAJEWSKI: Yes?
SPEAKER 1: All right.
So I have an app that has many
different customers in the
same Datastore.
All of my entities are keyed
on the customer ID field.
And I search on that
in all my queries.
How do I do the same thing
with full-text search?
Do I use the thing
to make multiple
indexes, one per customer?
Do I also add the same kind of
field to all of my full-text
search variables?
What's the right way
to go about this?
Will there be a multi-tenant
space in the name space in the
API added onto this?
How does that work?
BO MAJEWSKI: So the
recommendation would be to
indeed have index per customer
because you have the freedom.
I mean, we don't limit how many
indexes you have. At the
moment there are some
rudimentary limits put in
place, so you cannot create
millions of them in one day
because then we think there's
something wrong with the
application.
But in order to fully isolate
them, I would recommend using
customer name or some sort of
thing that identifies the
customer as the index name.
The reason for that is--
and I didn't mention
it in the talk--
we also plan to allow you, if
the customer says so, make the
given index accessible to
other applications.
So you can search it through
And then it would be easier just
to give that permission
per index rather than having
to juggle all these things.
So as far as we are concerned,
you can have thousands or tens
of thousands of indexes.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
But that will require using the
lowest level of index to
the search.
I can't just go with my data
objects as they are.
BO MAJEWSKI: No.
At the moment--
SPEAKER 1: [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
OK.
BO MAJEWSKI: That's
a fair comment.
And we can think about it,
how we would do it.
But there are some limits.
I mean, at the moment, we--
actually on Datastore
integration, we want to return
you all entities of a
given type and so.
SPEAKER 1: No, that's fine.
It'll take time.
It's pretty easy
to go that way.
Thanks.
BO MAJEWSKI: Sure.
SPEAKER 2: A couple of things.
Do you have the ability to mark
fields, certain fields,
as more important in terms
of the scoring?
BO MAJEWSKI: Ged?
GED ELLIS: There is--
yeah.
Field match boosts.
So you can put--
yeah, yeah, there's boosts
for field matching.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 2: And then,
fuzzy matching?
For misspellings?
BO MAJEWSKI: OK.
So we do stemming synonyms
and diacriticals.
But this is done at
the query time.
So if you want to match
something--
prefix matching, or
fuzzy matching?
SPEAKER 2: Um, yes.
BO MAJEWSKI: OK.
Yes.
So I'll say yes to
the first half.
Essentially, our approach
to stemming synonyms and
diacriticals is that it's better
to do it at a query
time because these
thing change.
We actually live in Australia.
And there was like Kevin '07
was the slogan, right?
And if you have Kevin--
if you enter two terms, Kevin
'07, then we in 2007 would
have realized that you're
talking about a particular
guy, Kevin Rudd.
Probably in 2004 it
was not relevant.
So you don't want to recompute
your index based on the year,
what is popular in a year.
So the additional processing is
done during the query time.
However, at this time, we
don't have anything that
allows you to say, anything
that starts with full.
And give me all these results.
That is one of the actually more
requested text search API
features, but we haven't quite
nailed it at this point.
SPEAKER 3: So this question is
about the industrial text
search API.
So if you have an entity in Java
or even Python, you have
this-- what appears to be search
by document editor.
It is an indication of how
we, in Python, use
the different search.
How do you search for normal
APIs [? in concrete ?]
items?
I mean, expand the models
of data [? stored? ?]
BO MAJEWSKI: At the moment, we
just allow you to do the
annotations on fields, right?
But in what--
expand the models?
SPEAKER 3: I know that
web-based, you use cache
management.
BO MAJEWSKI: To be honest,
that part has not been
implemented.
So if Max is anywhere in the
audience, he can probably
guess the answer.
But at the moment--
SPEAKER 4: So this API,
what's the objective?
Is it the [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
going to be exposed to us?
If you [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
the browser so that
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
only be used within the context
of my application?
And if so, can I get only the
pointer, which is the ID to
the entity and then have the
link, which the entity I came
from led us to?
What is the response
of the REST API?
I have two parts.
The [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
from the browser.
And the second part is, do
I get full entity data?
Or should I have only the point
at which the reader
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah.
I can tell you all these
at the moment.
So just the document.
You get the document.
And the main purpose of REST
API is to allow you to use
what hopefully is the goodness
of our text search API, even
if you don't have App
Engine application.
So how--
I'm not sure if returning
entities makes sense for
application.
Because it's meant for an
application that is not
necessarily a App Engine
application.
so
SPEAKER 4: You mean the
browser or inside the
applications App Engine
is configured?
BO MAJEWSKI: No, I mean if you
made the request from a
browser, and we gave you the
full entity, and you didn't
have an App Engine
application.
I know what--
SPEAKER 4: You will have
authentication problems?
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah.
I mean, authentication is
going follow the same
principle that Task Queue
was following.
So, yeah.
SPEAKER 4: Oh OK.
That's an administrative API.
SPEAKER 5: You talked about
pagination and cursors.
And I'm wondering if I'm using
a per document consistent
index, and I do a search, are
those-- the cursors and
pagination-- is that based on
a snapshot of what the index
looks like when I
did my search?
Or if things are being added to
that index, is it going to
bump my search results around?
GED ELLIS: The pagination
will be recomputed, so--
sorry, yeah.
The pagination will
be recomputed.
But for the cursor, it's a
good question on that.
I think it's actually-- we'll
take it from where
it was at that time.
BO MAJEWSKI: Well, yes.
I mean, if you change the
document-- if I understand you
correctly--
if you change the document, you
will not impact it because
the document ID stays
the same.
GED ELLIS: No, but if you
added more results.
SPEAKER 5: No, if I'm adding
more results, will it--
GED ELLIS: So for the first
case, when it's using pages,
it's going to recompute the
whole thing anyway.
But for the cursor, I'm not sure
what happens actually.
BO MAJEWSKI: We should
have tried it.
SPEAKER 5: Can I send you an
email and get back to you?
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah, sure.
GED ELLIS: Sure.
SPEAKER 6: So I heard about
Python and Java hook-up.
BO MAJEWSKI: Hm.
We didn't talk to
the go people.
GED ELLIS: They sit
next to us, so.
SPEAKER 6: That's pretty bad.
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
GED ELLIS: Yeah.
BO MAJEWSKI: Well, yes.
We'll politely ask
them to do that.
I mean, our back ends
are agnostic.
We just use our PCs.
And we just return our
protocol buffers.
So hopefully they can create
the appropriate
go object from it.
Essentially what you see is
there is an RPC and in front
of it sits a thin layer of Java
API or Python API that
reconstructs the Python object
or the Java object.
So I don't anticipate it's going
to be a major hassle to
get a go going.
SPEAKER 7: Another question
about data cursor.
I noticed in your examples,
they were all
next page, next page.
Can you go to previous page?
You know, like using
the data cursor?
BO MAJEWSKI: You could, but
you would have to store it
yourself, right?
So we always give you
the next one.
If you store it yourself, you
can actually do this.
So essentially, for us, the
way we store documents in
Megastore, the cursor tells
us the row from
which to start scanning.
That's all it is.
So if you have it, we
can start scanning
from earlier row.
But in HTML applications, it's
kind of difficult because then
you have to--
if you're on page five, you have
to maintain cursors from
the first four pages.
So this is why we-- actually,
the application uses cursors
rather than using paging because
we found out that we
had to maintain them and
all that sort of stuff.
SPEAKER 7: So is there a general
solution for that?
Like everyone has to
do it themselves.
And you're saying you have
to maintain all of it.
But what if somebody--
you have a thing that
says, page one,
page two, page three.
And they just want to
jump to page six.
And I haven't gone
there before, so.
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah,
so in that case--
GED ELLIS: In that case, you're
not using cursors.
You're just using offsets so you
don't need to record that.
You just give the page
number and the
actual size of the page.
You can randomly access
pages that way.
SPEAKER 8: On the Datastore
API, is there anything
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]
including the reference
properties in a document?
BO MAJEWSKI: Not at the moment,
but again valid remark.
We probably could just
do it by keys.
So you could then extract
the documents by keys.
At the moment, we didn't
implement it.
So, no.
SPEAKER 9: [? Could that be ?]
used for a document
[INAUDIBLE]
SPEAKER 8: Like if you have a
user reference property, you
could-- most people might
want to search by user?
BO MAJEWSKI: Yes.
That would be somewhat
complicated.
We would have to do multiple
traversal of the index.
But by all means, send
us a feedback.
And if we find that the raster
magicians can do it, why not?
SPEAKER 10: I have
two questions.
The first question is related
to the index space.
How do you configure it,
and can you monitor it?
BO MAJEWSKI: You will have in
your admin console the ability
to look at all indexes that you
have. So there would be a
list of all indexes your
application has.
And then once you drill into
an index, you will have the
metadata and--
GED ELLIS: Things like
sizing and--
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah.
Size of an index.
I mean, at the moment, it's
not real-time updated.
But it's probably going to be
like six hours lagging basic
statistics about the index.
Something like this.
SPEAKER 10: I have one other
question probably related to
the size question.
Are there any [UNINTELLIGIBLE]
on sharding and aggregation?
BO MAJEWSKI: I'm not sure.
So we actually shard
it internally.
I don't think this is part
of an application.
So once your index
grows large, you
get spread over multiple--
what we call them-- tablets.
So we don't want you to do it
explicitly at the moment.
It is done under the hood.
GED ELLIS: And by aggregation,
you mean things like in the
case of a user index, like an
inbox, you want to be able to
search all inboxes, over
all inboxes or
something like that?
Is that what you mean?
SPEAKER 10: Inboxes-- like
when you shard, you will
probably going to search
across the shards and
aggregate
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
GED ELLIS: Yeah.
It's already hemmed.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 11: The atom type, is
that just a short word for a
token of this type?
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah.
I have these weird preferences
of having
words of the same length.
So the first three that we did
was text, date, and then atom.
They all had four characters.
SPEAKER 12: If you have a field
that can change after
the document is indexed,
do you have to
re-index the whole document?
Say, I left the user tag
in the document.
GED ELLIS: It just
can't read it.
SPEAKER 13: I might have just
missed this, but when is it
available, and when will the
documentation be updated?
BO MAJEWSKI: Where's
the person who--
GED ELLIS: Dan.
He's hiding down
the back there.
BO MAJEWSKI: If you see like a
red mark on my chest, whatever
I'm answering, that means I'm
answering wrong because--
SPEAKER 13: Is that Dan
in the front row?
BO MAJEWSKI: No, he's actually
in back because he's got a
really long rifle.
So apparently we are supposed
to say we are
working very hard.
It actually works.
What you saw was no
smoke and mirrors.
But there is a few production
issues that we
need to push through.
SPEAKER 13: Will you go
pre-release on the local
before [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE]
BO MAJEWSKI: Again, I
have to judge his
eyebrows from a distance.
It's all going to
be announced.
And Mickey's going
to kill me if I--
you know, just one wrong
word, I'm dead.
Yeah.
Sorry.
I know it's not a satisfactory
answer, but this guy is scary.
SPEAKER 14: I just want
to say thank you.
I love it.
Thanks for doing it.
BO MAJEWSKI: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER 15: I want to ask
about a shortening
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
How about a proximity search?
For example, I have two
documents, ABC or ACB.
If I am searching A or B, the
key of ID for both documents
are the same, but can
I get the ABC first?
GED ELLIS: That's
a good question.
I'm not sure if that scorer
does that as well, but is
proximity in the backend?
BO MAJEWSKI: I don't know.
That's my answer.That's a very
lame answer, but kind of
honest for the moment.
So yeah.
Good feedback.
I mean, if you can either
add it to Issue 217 or
something like this.
I mean, we definitely--
GED ELLIS: We're aware of
proximity search, but whether
it's actually supported in that
scorer, I'm not sure.
SPEAKER 16: For a different kind
of proximity description
for this session, you
mentioned geosearch.
How does that work?
BO MAJEWSKI: So you record a
point so you can create a
field, which you specify that
this is a location.
And you need to specify the
longitude, latitude for us.
And then there is a function,
which is a distance.
And so you can search by
anything that has distance
less than 10 kilometers.
And give it a higher boost. So I
don't know how you'd use it,
but you can use all
these functions.
Like greater than 10 kilometers,
give it one.
Otherwise give it miles.
Give it five.
Or you can just sort by
a distance from a
given point as well.
GED ELLIS: Yeah.
But you can use it as a restrict
in your search as
well as sort by the distance.
SPEAKER 16: To prioritize?
To sort?
GED ELLIS: Yeah.
Exactly.
BO MAJEWSKI: Yeah.
But when you search, we use this
stupid thing, which is,
we assume that you can fly.
So.
SPEAKER 16: Yeah.
All right.
Thank you.
GED ELLIS: Thank you.
BO MAJEWSKI: All right.
I think that's a wrap.
Thank you very much.